man kann sagen wir leben in seltsamen
zeiten liebe zuschauer und eigentlich
kann mich nicht mehr viel schockieren
das muss ich sagen aber diese woche ist
eine sache passiert die hat mich echt
umgehauen
da fliegt mir doch der kitt aus der
brille was ist denn hier los die cdu ist
plötzlich eine demokratische partei
hammer oder war das der hammer gegen den
ausdrücklichen befehl der kanzlerin
wählt die cdu fraktion nicht wie seit
1000 jahren volker kauder zu ihrem chef
nein sondern hier den dings nach sagt
ihnen der name ralph brinkhaus etwas
weil hier möchte man fragen ralph
brinkhaus
was ist das vor allem der ist der neue
fraktionschef brinkhaus na das ist
spannende sache
[Applaus]
ist
[Musik]
ralph brinkhaus jahre lang
stellvertreter von kauder und selbst der
wusste nicht wer brinkhaus ist ja nach
13 jahren merkel ist die arme cdu nur
noch eine leere hülle und wollte halt
irgendwas neues irgendwas nur wenn es
nur ein steuerberater aus rheda
wiedenbrück ist ein ganz ganz typischer
ostwestfale wenn er ganz crazy drauf ist
der brinkhaus dann blättert er verträumt
in den ordner mit seinen größten erfolg
ich habe gesagt guck mal an die kleine
cdu wird plötzlich erwachsenen zieht bei
mutti aus bald wer hätte das gedacht
bitter natürlich diese woche für merkel
und für den volker denn ja klar in der
ja das ist das ist nicht schön volker
kauder hatte vorher nie einen
gegenkandidaten und dann verliert hat
direkte man könnte auch sagen er hat
alle seine kampfkandidatur ein fall für
den boxer ist mir scheiß bilanz aber mir
wird da trotzdem fehlen
[Musik]
jeden tag zwei drei weizenbier genießen
ein paar sein
ein
nein
[Musik]
wir werden jetzt auch eine gute
zusammenarbeit mit dem neuen
fraktionsvorsitzenden haben
[Applaus]
weiter
volker kauder
hier könnten ihr könnt sagen was ihr
wollt volker kauder wahrscheinlich einer
der besten cdu-fraktionsvize die wir in
den letzten 13 jahren habe ich in meiner
top 3 sein abgang ist für viele experten
so etwas wie der anfang vom ende der ära
merkel da könnte was dran sein ich meine
demokratie lebt halt vom wechsel
deswegen haben die amerikaner eine
amtszeit begrenzung immerhin unsere
groko gelobt einmal mehr zur sogenannten
sacharbeit zurückzukehren kommt jetzt
immer wieder
ich denke wow sacharbeit einfach mal das
machen wofür man bezahlt wird verrückt
oder völlig unerträglich ist derweil
allerdings das schadenfrohe feixte der
afd
wie fröhlich wie vor die presse getreten
sind nach dem kauder debakel hier alles
weide summt vor glück wie so ein frisch
verliebter backfisch sie können sich
vorstellen bei uns knallen die korken
[Gelächter]
borken
[Applaus]
[Musik]